à leur décharge disant que les
organisateurs ont eu à subir la
concurrence de la traction servis à
domicile que constituer la
retransmission du mondial
ensuite le retentissement de cette fête
de la musique
souffrant visiblement d'impréparation
aura été inversement proportionnelle à
la dimension de son casque et dans les
petites villes comme ici avance on a pu
plus facilement réunir les musiciens
amateurs et leurs instruments disparates
indispensable à l'investissement de
l'art en autres attraits les ont répondu
sont nombreux et surtout surtout des
jeunes
oui il ya des gens comme vous voyez il
ya même des spécificités commence à la
maternelle déjà qu'est ce que c'est
oui comment ça marche et loire madame de
passage et ils doivent être grand mais
c'est pas on l'a mis entre les mains
l'ombre c'est très simple à manipuler
est ce que vous êtes d'accord sur
l'organisation d'une journée pour la
musique et on organise régulièrement de
la musique il y en a au moins deux à
trois points et les 100 par mois
intenses et agde musica l'émietter ça
dépend en général selon vous c'est une
idée qui peut aller loin cette journée
nationale de la musique c'est
merveilleux en train de retrouver tout
le monde entier de la france qui sort
dans la rue et joue de la musique
céleste fantastique entre gentils
garçons leur maintenance salué l'arrivée
de l'automne et de l'hiver et du
printemps et plus seulement devrait
toutefois pas tous les jours
enfin